Hey,
what's going on?
It still burns time for the Monday morning podcast for,
uh,
October 19th,
2015.
How's it go and how I,
uh,
I'm on the road now.
I'm on the road again chicka boom chicka boom,
boom,
boom.
I had,
you can't wait to eat on the road again.
Well,
you know what?
I can't wait to get on the road again because I'm an old man and I'm out here
and I'm cold.
Ah,
God,
I love the Midwest,
but it's right,
right when the fucking winter starts.
This can be kind of a motherfucker,
you know,
it is.
This takes me back to my days.
Back in the day when I was young and I had more freckles,
um,
and I used to do,
uh,
okay.
I used to do all the college gigs out here.
Um,
you know,
my agent a Bass Shula,
you still always book me.
Um,
they were based out,
it's still are based out of Chicago and they used to just booked me in like
Duluth de Moines,
the quad cities,
Hayes,
Nebraska,
Grand Junction,
Colorado.
Colorado wasn't as bad because you had the rocky mountains to look at and you
can be like,
oh my God,
looks like a beer commercial.
You,
yeah.
That guy who does those fucking ram commercials.
What's his name?
Sam Elliott.
We'd get on their cores beer brewed in the rocky mountains.
No,
it isn't.
They don't have a factory up in the rocky mountains.
They don't.
It's on the flatlands.
It's probably somewhere in Denver,
although the rent's probably too high.
I don't know where it is.
Where the fucking you fucking shuttle in illegal immigrants in and out the back
door and nobody will see it.
You know,
that's not up in that.
You're not going to get illegal immigrants to go up to a fucking mountain right
there already.
Like listen to it.
I already swam across the fucking filthy river to get in here.
Okay.
I'm not walking up a mountain,
you know,
if you're going to fucking exploit me.
Okay.
With my labor,
we're doing it right here.
And then they go.
I build a factory around them.
Um,
maybe it ends up in the mountains.
I have no idea.
I just remember at one point I W I was rafting,
not rafting.
I was in like a little inner tube going down the river with a bunch of other
fucking people that was to same river.
Oh that's right.
We went by the chorus factory.
I'm like,
this is the fucking factory
with all those,
you know those Denver hippies,
there is specific kinds of hippie for Denver hippie.
You know what their action sandals,
you know saying sorta look at those hippy toes kind of thing.
But they also have that look like,
you know they're going to go swing on a rope and jump into a fucking lake.
Those Denver hit piece,
you know them,
they're like fucking ski instructors for their whole lives.
Right?
Like 50 you still got long hair,
you know,
fucking door and buy one of those squirrel suits when I was flying squirrel
suits like that type of shit.
Right.
I think I went from hippies into a,
I don't know what those people are.
Those people who jump off of buildings with their parachute watered up in the
hand,
like a,
like a bouquet at a wedding,
you know,
for them,
they just throw it away except it saves their life.
You know?
I don't mind that those cons do it.
It just bugs me that they have to film it.
You know what I mean?
You know,
if you awesome,
I can't just be awesome.
I just go do it.
Get off the fact that you got to film it,
that really knocks it down for me.
You never saw superman with a little fucking Gopro on did you?
He just fucking went out and save people.
Then he goes home,
he puts his fucking Janeane Garofalo glasses back on.
He goes back.
Do you know it goes back to the fucking,
the newspaper
do Clark Kent couldn't close it.
Fucking piece of pussy if it,
he never,
he never banged glow.
A slight daddy.
I mean,
granted she had a crush on a superhero,
but you know,
you can work on her in securities law.
Was she not going to land that I'm right here and let's make a life together.
I give you take off my navy blue trousers over here and do something.
Give me a little help.
Can we get the Kryptonite out?
Am I nuts?
Sale lowly.
Right.
Okay.
You fucking assholes jumping around on those little flying squirrel suits.
It's just,
you know,
I don't understand why you need to fill the need.
You have to film yourself
to be a little more super math.
Yeah.
All right.
Little,
a little less.
Uh,
Colorado Rocky Mountain Hippie,
all,
they're the worst.
They're the worst.
You know,
when you go to San Francisco and you run into a Hippie,
it's like you expect it.
You know what I mean?
That's right.
All the leaves are Brown and the sky is gray.
I have dirty,
see,
sorry.
Sorry.
Excuse me.
There's,
you can kind of carry it to him.
Um,
when you are rocky mountain,
so wait,
what do you expect?
Do you expect you're going to see that guy walking around
okay.
With the orange crush barrel around them?
Remember that guy?
I think he died the guy,
he's got all the Broncos games.
Yeah.
You know,
expect,
you're going to see that.
You're going to see some,
a frontier kind of ladies,
right?
You expect to see Sam Elliott drinking of course,
course light,
the silver bullet.
That's what you expect to see.
And then you show up.
And this just says new fucking hippie.
The shippy that skis pippies don't ski,
right?
He'd be stone base jump
does special kind of heat when you're up there too.
And the mile high city,
by the way.
How about,
how about a hand for the Cleveland Browns?
This,
this week,
you know,
finding 87,
possibly 88 ways to lose that game to the Denver Broncos grand.
The Broncos were fucking up to
unreal when fucking,
uh,
pate and through that pick,
if he light through it,
it would have been dropped.
You know,
fucking Eli is the,
the,
I'm telling you,
I don't ever want to see that guy on the other side of the field.
Again,
the football gods love Eli manic
unless he plays the eagles.
The Eagles always played the giants tough.
There's always that one team.
You know there's always that one fucking Achilles' son,
but I swear to God if he like threw that ball,
you know that the light back of went right to him.
He would have been like,
oh,
I'm taking over your date and he would have dropped it and Eli would have got
there with his face all mushed into that fucking helmet and he does look at it
like Eli.
He looks so dumb in a helmet.
He should be was still wearing his dockers with this pads underneath it,
you know?
But you know,
God damn well Eli's going to go down the field.
He's going to throw a fucking ball.
Somebody is going to catch it between their helmet and [inaudible].
It's just,
it's over.
Even when he fucks up like just shit,
just it's over.
If you cannot beat them in,
at some point the glass slippers got a turn back into a pumpkin.
That's my prediction this year is Eli is going to throw a pick and a big
situation and for the first time in his career somebody is actually going to
hold onto it.
That's what I'm hoping anyways.
Alright,
plowing ahead here.
So Peyton throws a pic cause he's not,
he and the football gods don't like Payton because Payton has god like numbers
and they're intimidated by it.
They look at Eli,
they go,
oh well look at this guy.
He's got a cold or something.
I don't know what she's got.
The mumps,
what's going on with his cheeks.
So paint and throws the ball,
the fucking,
the browns intercepted.
There aren't like they're on the fucking on Denver's 39 yard line to tie fucking
game.
I can't remember it was overtime or not.
I had bad,
a bad single signal on the bus there.
Right.
And um,
all right,
so they're,
they're on 39 first and first and 10.
You're on the 39 yard line football fans.
How long a field goal is that?
Huh?
Come on dude.
A little douche bag.
Do the math.
Um,
he had 10 yards for the end zone.
That's 49 yards plus eight yards.
When they got to hike it,
49 and eight is 57.
It's a 57 Yada.
So they basically need to get,
they need to get a first down.
Okay.
Move the ball fucking forward.
So at the very least,
you know,
you can take a long shot at a field goal.
47 yards.
No walk in the park with these fucking kids can,
they can do it today.
Yeah.
Are you,
when they're little,
they kick in virtual reality field goals right into their flat screen TV.
You've seen the videos.
All of a sudden they sneaker comes off and breaks the TV and everybody laughs.
Ha Ha Hee.
He,
what happened was throw that fucking thing.
I'll get another $800 fucking TV.
And where does that flat screen go?
Why is there anybody out there that can repair a flat screen TV?
When I was a kid,
when you had those fucking square TVs,
it's more on the legs that weighed like 900 pounds.
Weigh heavier than a flatscreen.
Right.
Get up like a fucking flatscreens like a,
okay.
Like a giant fucking iPhone,
you know,
basically relatively the weight.
You know those old school fucking square TVs,
you know,
it was like,
I don't,
I don't know why they were like a safe,
couldn't move those fucking things.
But still we did.
You moved it out the door and somebody fixed it and you came back to give it a
new tube.
I don't understand why you can't prepare anything nowadays.
Then everybody's like,
ah,
you know,
Oh,
you broke the TV and then it ends up in the fucking ocean.
Right.
Get the fucking thing fixed.
You can't do,
you know,
my wife got our microwave fixed,
so excited.
I'm so excited.
I don't even use the microwave because a long time ago I was doing a fucking
show and one of the actors on there said,
hey,
you know,
I don't,
I don't need anything out of a microwave.
I said,
Oh really?
That,
that's begin.
Why is that?
And he's like,
well,
they did an experiment where a,
they water these plants with water and they water these other plants of water
that had been stuck in a microwave for like a minute each day.
Each day they microwaved the water and uh,
there was no nutrition,
no nutrients left.
So I guess it doesn't really cause any cancer or anything,
but it just got a nuke.
Saul,
you're fucking so,
there's nothing in there.
You just,
you're eating like space is what you're eating.
You beating,
someone's going to fill up the space and your stomach is what I'm trying to say.
Right.
Don't make any fucking sense.
I Dunno.
I have no idea.
I'm laying in a fucking bed here in Fort Wayne,
Indiana.
What do you want from me?
The creepy downtown of Fort Wayne,
Indiana.
Jesus Christ.
What do I didn't get?
Let me get back to the game here.
So they fucking,
uh,
so he throws the pick and what are they do?
They got three fucking place.
The very least.
You're got to run three place to advance the fucking ball.
First play.
They lose two yards.
Now it's a 59 yards.
The next play they take a fucking sack for like 10 yards.
Now it's like a 70 yarder and then they fucking ran it like a content at the guy
just falls down.
Maybe it was two runs in a sec.
I can't remember what.
And then they got to punt the ball away.
You know what I did?
Cause I've watched enough football on my life.
I shut the fucking TV off because I rather liked that too.
The old,
that's the game.
It's a game right there.
You had your fucking opportunity and you blow it.
You know,
it's like that brought it work.
That chicken school,
you should have asked out and you didn't do it.
You know.
Hey,
you are years later tracking it down on fucking Facebook.
All right,
so over fucking over it.
Let it go.
Same thing with the brunch.
It's fucking over.
So anyways,
like I said,
I'm here with downtown.
Um,
okay,
I'm in downtown,
uh,
Fort Wayne here are going to drive down to Cincinnati and uh,
I love it out here man.
I mean I don't like when all the crop to cut down.
It isn't quite that time yet.
That's the worst when you're out here in like February and the crops are cut
down right.
And it's overcast and overcast sky,
you know,
cause it's so fucking flat.
You can actually look,
look out as you're driving down these country roads,
you see where the overcast guide meets the ground and the crops are cut down,
dude.
And you know,
I never understood how a band like slipknot came from fucking Iowa.
I'm like,
what the fuck are they so god damn angry about?
Yeah,
you're already and milking cows,
you know?
Yeah.
Meeting chicks on farmers only dotcom.
I mean,
there's a lot,
a lot to be happy,
but out here,
and when I went out there in February,
I was like,
okay,
I get it now.
I get it.
There's nothing to fucking do out here.
Eight,
seven,
six shakes,
shakes five,
right?
And all of a sudden it all starts making fence.
That's making fence making sense?
Um,
there's fucking God screen saving thing.
Fucking come shoot with
five seconds.
I've got to put my password.
And why are they acting like I'm so fucking important?
I know a young counselor,
oh,
go into your settings and you go into your fucking settings.
You don't look at this.
I know my fucking password is,
I never get it right the first time.
Oh Jesus Christ combined.
Uh,
did I forget my password?
This will be fucked up,
so it'd be embarrassing.
Come on,
come on,
come on.
Come on one time.
One time.
Daddy needs a winner.
Right?
There we go.
Just click on your finder and go into the settings and hit application.
Um,
I about the patriots.
Beat the colts.
Great game.
Andrew.
Luck's a fucking man,
dude.
The guy's a fucking man.
I love watching that guy play.
Um,
he's not a whiner.
Takes his head.
So he gets back up,
he helps the guy up.
We'll hit him.
He's just a fucking stud.
And I'm,
I really realized that when I watched it last night that it wasn't,
I'm not,
I don't hate the colts.
I Hate Jerry Jerry Jones.
I hate gym or say I hate the fucking owner.
Um,
it's,
I hate a lot of their fans.
I had fun last night in Fort Wayne.
I was trying to get them to admit it.
I go,
come on.
You guys admit it.
Admit it.
The lights are down.
No one can see you admitted.
You lost by 38 points.
All right.
It wasn't because of the air pressure.
Come on,
be honest with yourselves.
Somebody said Tom Brady was gay or he's a fag or something like that know.
And uh,
I just went on this whole riff about how beautiful a man Tom Brady was,
you know,
and how beautiful his wife was.
And that deep inside I was talking to the person in the crowd that they realize,
okay,
that genetically
they had no hope of,
of like a woman like Jyzelle ever.
Okay.
Really ever seeing them for who they are.
Like they could literally walk into the room with their head on fire and GSL
still wouldn't notice them.
And as they watched Tom Brady marched down the field towards yet another
championship somewhere in there and that brain,
okay,
the truth of that is,
is screaming at them
and went to a dark place,
whatever.
I'm in the fucking Midwest starting to cut the crops down.
Um,
I was at the embassy theater last night and,
uh,
I actually watched this whole video on that eye level theaters that were going
to get fucking torn down as people saved them.
That's actually,
um,
one of my soft spots as far as,
uh,
something I could get behind.
I actually did a Gig in Fresno and I talked to the guy and he was like,
still trying to raise money.
They keep that thing going and I that reminded me how I told them I was going to
go up there,
maybe do a show or something like that.
I can't remember.
It was in Fresno if it was the one in Bakersfield,
I don't remember.
But they both great theaters and um,
I watched this whole video on it and like,
like Bob Hope had his first Mc Gig here just to the level,
they always have the same history.
These old theories was always like,
it was a Vaudeville theater,
you know,
and then it became a movie theater and then,
uh,
you know,
it starts to go down and like the late fifties and sixties,
it becomes a porno house.
And then in the 70s,
they were going to tear it down and then somebody came in and saved the fucking
thing and now it's awesome again.
And uh,
they'll embassy theater basically had that same thing.
Minus the Porno House.
It was never a porno house,
which makes sense here because they don't sell booze on Sundays.
Like all the liquor stores are closing,
only sell beer out here.
But um,
do they got,
they got a minor league,
whatever basketball team out here.
It's called the mad ants.
How fucking hilarious.
A fucking great name.
The Fort Wayne mad ants.
Um,
I'm a nerd for this shit.
I love this stuff out here.
I used to have family lived out here,
you know,
way back,
like a hundred years ago.
And they had a farm.
This is the,
I have this weird connection out,
even though I didn't grow up out here on my blood line is from out here.
Indiana,
Michigan,
Ohio,
all alleged shit.
So I have this weird connection when I come out here.
Um,
you know,
I have family lived in Wisconsin and all these places that I'm going to select,
they're going to,
the city was Chicago,
you know,
that was a big deal.
And,
um,
so anyways,
and I was hoping when I was going to go to Chicago that the fucking cops were
going to be in the world series.
How exciting would that be?
And I now look at it,
oh by the way,
can we go back a second?
Those tow,
I don't understand people who thought that we were going to beat the cults by a
thousand fucking points.
The coach made it to the AFC championship game.
I just don't fucking understand how people look at it.
And ESPN hyped it up that way.
And then during the game they're going like,
whoa,
what's going on here?
Everybody thought that they were going to it.
It's like what?
Cause Tom Brady's dad says score fucking 60 points on them.
All of a sudden that's the line that's like watching Toronto playing Kansas
City.
They hit one walk off home,
run and flip their fucking mullets,
you know?
And do you know in all your fucking actors run in musical theater,
that attitude run where they start to run sideways looking at the crowd and then
dude,
like the head whip and then fucking run off stage with their arms dangling
behind them.
That's how Toronto ran the bases.
And everybody's like,
Oh shit.
He come the Blue Jays.
Okay,
given Kansas City,
no respect whatsoever.
Kid just said he went to the dance last year.
They almost won the fucking world series and it comes Toronto.
These dirty filthy bird counts come waltzing in like it's a foregone conclusion
that they go on to the world series.
And now look at you.
You got the old right there,
Fred,
you download toe.
All.
Alright,
so why don't you quit flipping your fucking batch and get back to playing the
Goddamn game.
So a fan like me can enjoy a nice seven game series.
Now look at you get dumb cunt.
She got to win four out of five.
So anyways,
um,
I love Kansas City,
man.
I love the fucking rails.
It goes way back in the day when the red sox could never beat the fucking
Yankees.
And like,
like three times in four years.
Kansas City played a,
played the Yankees and the,
for the panel is how they used to say it,
the plane for the pattern.
It wasn't the ALC s back then,
it was just just for the pennant.
Right.
Let's just make it nice.
You sit on the corner selling newspapers for nickel step right up,
step right up.
Eric strikes to read all about it.
Dodge has a new car called the Yotpo.
Um,
and that's the way it was 1977.
so they played him as 77 and 78 and lost and then they played him at 81 or play
them an 80 and one and then lost to the Phillies in the,
uh,
in the world.
Serious there.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
I got this weird thing.
I like the Toronto Blue Jays.
I don't want them winning our world series.
I feel like our world series trophy belongs here in America.
It's one of the weird like patriotic things that I have,
like Toronto played the Yankees,
I'd actually root for the Yankees as much as it would kill me.
But you know what the fuck do I care?
They got 27 championships,
so I give a shit.
If they get 28 we're not catching them.
Right.
It's a foregone conclusion.
You know,
they went on the run,
whoever it goes on the run early on,
you know,
they,
they have it forever.
Fucking Montreal when you fucking win.
And I'm like before the titanic sank and nobody's going to catch,
if you went on a run back then you're not getting it.
There was like nine fucking teams and yeah,
he had to win like two to play off series.
Dude in baseball.
Do you know if you won the division that was winning the pennant?
There was no afcs,
no wildcard,
no nothing.
He just immediately went to the world series.
So you had to win one playoff series.
So I've got to tell you,
I got this weird thing with that.
Like,
you know,
even like the Celtics when we were in one,
like have we won 11 in a row or nine in a row,
11 and fucking,
you know,
13 years or something like that.
I mean,
come on,
come on.
You kidding.
That's,
that's beer league shit.
That's what's so amazing about the Lakers is we did that in the Lakers,
still came and caught us.
I mean that's why I think,
you know,
they're the greatest fucking franchise in the modern era since 1973 and they won
more championships than anybody since then.
And as much as it fucking kills me to say that it's true,
it's fucking true.
Um,
day.
That devastating combination of,
of they knew how to pick talent and then when it came into the free agency era,
uh,
they knew how to play that game and we didn't.
And that hurt us.
And also Len bias,
Diane fucked us out of at least one to three championships depending on who you
talk to,
a white God blend.
We got Len bias in 1986 our strongest fucking team.
And then we're going to have Len bias.
Basically Jordan light was we've,
I mean we will also accent.
I'm like,
oh finally I have a Celtic that can dunk,
you know,
cause all the Celtics fans,
as much as they didn't want to admit it,
it watching the showtime Lakers was so much fucking fun if they weren't playing
the Celtics cause then you're rooting for the Celtics.
But I used to watch them all the fun they were on TV.
I loved watching the Lakers fucking showtime,
like it's become a man.
And I was actually talking last night when we were on the bus hanging out and we
were watching a,
the end of the Patriots was so fucking great man.
We had the bus right behind the theater and the theater of hooked us up like a
nine pack of Miller lights with the giant fucking opening,
you know,
so you can pour it down you fucking bass mouth.
And uh,
we were sitting in there for,
as he was finishing up a cigar outside,
right.
And we were talking about,
uh,
Barton,
it goes,
all right,
your,
your mount Rushmore
of football coaches.
And he said Lombardi,
Chuck,
Bill Walsh,
Bill Bellacheck.
And I said the exact same thing I said,
I say,
except not chuck Noll.
Um,
okay.
And I picked a,
what's his face?
I just spaced on his fucking name.
Um,
Don Cory,
L.
Eric Korey yell.
I just thought he was ahead of his fucking time and uh,
it really informed,
I think Bill Walsh coming up with the fucking a west coast offense.
There was nothing more exciting
than in the late seventies,
early eighties.
The San Diego chargers on Monday night football,
knowing that they were going to throw the ball on first down at you.
You don't understand what the f what a game changer that was 10 years away from
three yards and a cloud of dust.
We just fucking ran it,
ran it,
ran it.
And then you just throw it if you had to,
which is why Johnny Unitas as fucking numbers are insane.
The fact that he threw for 41,000 yards during the fifties and sixties is
fucking insane.
And which is why he's always in my top three,
four quarterbacks of all time.
But anyways to watch.
I don't know.
I absolutely loved those guys.
Um,
okay.
I know how the fuck I got onto that thing.
Let me read some advertising here before.
Uh,
I completely space out here.
We've got a couple of new people here.
We always got new people.
It's a revolving door here in this fucking podcast with the advertising.
All right,
nuts.com everybody that talking about she bowls,
important message for all the nut matures in my audience.
So Jesus,
here we go.
If was good and you got to fucking,
I would have done all this.
You're going to do it for me.
A why?
By small nuts@thegrocerystorewhenyoucangetbigbeautifulnutsfromnuts.com.
Start with the nut joke.
Oh,
this is for me.
What do you have when you have nuts on your chest?
Chest nuts.
Sorry,
I just had to take a long pause there.
When it's a bad joke like that.
You just got to just go stare at the person that wrote it.
What do you have if you have nuts on your wall?
Walnuts.
You had all your nuts.
Nuts dot comm.
Uh,
you can find this incredible website that I'm going to tell you about once a,
I tell you the name,
you're going to have a,
you give them a hard time forgetting not startcom.
They have in their opinion the best tasting nuts on the planet.
You get it.
This is one big Dick joke.
Everybody.
nuts.com is the simple and convenient way to have nutritious,
delicious,
healthy nuts and so many other tasty treats from around the world delivered
straight to your door.
Is it hard to get peanuts?
Uh,
right now new customers can get for free samples.
Choose from over 50 options.
That is something interesting.
I didn't know there was that many nuts out there.
That's a $50 value when you go to nuts.com click on the mic and enter my code.
Burr burs.
Since 1929,
his family owned business has prided themselves on delivering the best nuts and
dried fruit.
You'll find anywhere a got a love of family business.
Only the freshest products from the best suppliers in the world.
Easy to use.
Site lets you search exactly what you are looking for.
Can buy the case by the pound certified organic,
certified gluten free,
whatever that means.
With or without salt,
raw sugar free,
100% satisfaction guaranteed and not stock.
Eskom is more than just nuts.
Choose from over 3000 healthy snacks including a dried fruit,
sweet treats,
chocolate covered nuts.
Every flavor of gummy bear,
monkey munch,
monkey much.
What the fuck is,
I feel like that's what we're going to be eating after the dollar collapses.
You know,
we're all microchipped freedom to monkey much.
I'm cooking and baking goods,
almond flour,
Chia seeds,
spices,
grains,
any powder you want to throw in there and it's in your smoothie.
Sugar and gluten free.
Look at you guys.
You guys got the goods here.
Why'd you go with the silly jokes up there?
You know what it is,
is because I did that fucking uh,
uh,
whatever the one was.
I fucking laugh my balls off on the,
on the,
on the copies and everybody tries to fucking lead me there.
He can't make it happen.
Either it just happens or it doesn't.
To fucker Sherry's berries.
That was a thing.
Almond flour,
Chia seeds,
add Semick gluten free coffees,
teas over 39 different kinds of coffee.
107 flavors here,
tens basket,
Buzzer,
nuts,
nuts.com.
Big Salty,
sweet,
whatever kind you like to munch on.
Let them take care of you.
Uh,
right now,
could new customers get for free samples?
That's a $15 value when you go to nuts dot Camidge my code name Berbee you are.
That's nuts.com.
Enter my code burr for free for free samples.
All right,
go to nuts.com full details.
trunk club.
Everybody shopping is awful.
You know,
that's one of those things we started looking at the side of your girl's head
and you just start thinking like,
what if,
when she looked at me,
I made a weird face and just ran away,
you know,
pass the car into the woods and she didn't never saw me again.
That's the kind of things that I think when I go shopping who has the patience
for crowded stores or the time to try on 10 pairs of pants that don't even fit
well,
but well,
why don't you ask somebody to tell you your size but is the problem you still
want to look great.
Exactly.
And with Trunk Club,
you never have to set foot in a mall again.
Sign me up,
especially with the fucking holidays coming,
right?
You want to look good at your holiday parties.
Uh,
Trunk Club takes the hassle man out of shopping by shipping you a trunk of
clothes that fit perfectly and make you look like 1 million bucks with all the
new styles@trunkclubslash.com slash burr you simply answer some questions about
your styles,
your preferences and sizes,
and they're your and size.
In our assigned and expert stylist,
they cure rate clothes from the best premium brands and you approve of what you
like.
And just like that a trunk arrives on your doorstep filled with handpicked
clothes that are perfect for you.
Try them on,
keep what you like and easily return.
What you don't in their prepaid trunk.
This is not a subscription service.
You only paid for the clothes you keep from your trunk.
No hidden charges,
just great clothes.
Uh,
get started today.
And Trunk Club will style you for free plus free shipping both ways.
You only pay for clothes you keep to take advantage.
Go to trunk club.com/bar one last time.
That's trunk club.com/ [inaudible] for a trunk.
Philip clothes full of clothes you'll love wearing.
All right.
How many more of these are there?
There's two more.
Let's,
uh,
let's break it up to my fucking brain is tired today.
I'm tired this morning.
Oh,
Jesus.
I'm tardy.
Alberto's Bruins.
How about those fucking Bro,
they won two games in a row.
Why am I singing the Notre Dame Song?
Oh,
that's right.
I went to the game.
Um,
yeah,
I went to the Notre Dame game.
Everybody,
that's a bucket list thing.
I could just,
uh,
I could just knock that right off.
Now where the fuck is all my,
my notes here?
I had all the subjects I wanted to talk about.
What the fuck is this?
Oh,
for God sakes,
why does this,
you know what it is?
I always have 50 fucking windows open.
Okay,
let's close this one.
Let's close this one.
Look at it.
It's a fucking enigma.
Where,
where did it go?
Where does the window go?
Now you won't go up.
Is this it?
Come on.
There it is.
All right.
Beautiful.
Um,
anyways,
what was I talking about?
I want you to Notre Dame gay man.
What a fucking game.
There was absolutely no defense.
And you know what?
I finally broke the curse.
I'm no longer at Jenks the home team one congratulations to Notre Dame.
Um,
my God,
it was crazy walking that campus.
It was really weird.
I walked out last time I walked that campus was like,
I was a freshman in high school and I was out here visiting a family.
You know,
we went down to go look at it and I was all excited to see the stadium and uh,
faking that I was actually going to get grades good enough to go there and I was
going to go to law school and become a lawyer.
And uh,
that was like 30 fucking years ago.
The comebacks,
30 years later,
dude,
was more than 30 years ago.
It was like around 83,
84.
God,
I'm an old motherfucker now.
It's 2015 and it come back
drunk as a standup comedian
walking that campus,
just thinking,
what the fuck happened?
Just thinking all this shit that happened to me since then.
I remember I was walking,
you know,
hammered of course and uh,
laughing as I was walking the campus and I,
when you kind of took a different route there,
bill it,
this family of sober people just kind of looked over at me and I was just like,
okay.
And I'm going down memory lane here,
a little shit face.
Cut me some slack.
Last time I was here,
Ronnie Reagan was still alive and he was eating jelly beans,
right?
Blaming everything on all the north.
Um,
all right.
The Jesus Christ.
What a fucking game.
We saw a game where there was over a thousand yards offense was absolutely no
defense.
And I gotta tell you something.
I get so fucking livid.
It fans from the other team at home games of teams that I have now,
I don't have a dog in the fight.
Don't give a shit.
There was two USC fans that would drive me nuts.
There was one Samoan look and dude I was calling him Mosey to,
to pursue and he patriot fans.
You remember that?
He probably wasn't even Simone.
Remember most these mousses and you'd be in the fucking end zone.
Oh,
ah,
Moshi.
It's a fucking incredible player for the Patriots.
Like all Samoans are
okay.
You know,
USC for some reason they had the lock on some and players and they realized that
these guys are like,
they'd like,
they're not even good players.
They're like hall of fame players.
Yeah.
For some reason they were the only ones that were drafted.
Them are going out there and flying out and talking to their mother's lying to
him saying,
your kid is going to make the fucking NFL and we're going to fucking fix up your
fucking house out here.
Whatever the fuck they tell these goddamn kids.
Um,
so he was doing that shit and every time you know Notre Dame first play like
throws a fucking 70 yard bomb for a touchdown and he does that stupid thing.
You know where your team just got scored on and then you sit there and nod and
like,
okay,
like we can handle this,
we can handle this.
And you want to be like,
excuse me sir,
you're not on the team.
What are you nodding for?
And then there was this fucking old white guy with the most faded fucking USC
jacket and hat.
So you tell he was a fucking real fan who sat out there in the La Coliseum.
I mean it was like sun damaged clothes that he was wearing.
It was just like his skin,
you know,
white people will wear shit till it's fallen off a fucking bodies.
You know what I mean?
I'm telling you,
we're fucking,
I dunno what we are.
We're sentimental and cheap.
We don't fucking put lotion on our faces or faces his off.
Are All fucking sun damaged.
Skye was a mess,
man.
This guy looked like a fucking dust bowl farmer and you know,
he was from La,
right?
One of those Douche bags and they both bonded and they kept high fiving each
other and they were fucking annoying me.
And I was sitting there going,
why am I so mad that these UFC fans are USC fence?
I just hate it when the other team's fans coming in and they take over the
fucking stadium.
But when I was psyched about who's sitting around all Notre Dame fans except for
this one,
USC Douche who showed up in the third quarter with this girlfriend wearing this
like camel hair coat,
it almost seemed with the scarf draped over it.
And
it was just such a fuck I had,
he was such a Douche.
He was such a Douche.
She had to like respect it.
Um,
he just looked like that guy you were going to see on American greed when he was
in his fifties,
just complete sociopath.
Completely entitled the whole fucking thing.
Like you know,
they have that expression.
He's a comic's comic,
you know,
a musician's musician.
This kid we would joke and was,
he was like,
the Douche is Douche,
like Douche bags.
When we looked at him like,
oh look,
he's fucking crushing it
at one point,
my favorite part of the game,
because you know,
he was a USC fan of here I'm talking,
I'll douchey and loudly and Notre Dame was down on the goal line and they stack
like three receivers on one side and he's just like,
look at that formation.
Why would they stick all those guys?
And then of course,
Notre Dame runs it up the middle for a touchdown.
And I just turned around and look at him.
I said,
oh it's cause it clears out the middle and it means like,
oh we're not even good this year.
That's what he said.
Ugh,
I swear to fucking choke him,
right?
This God damn scarf and listening to him losing faith.
Like I just want to,
I like the old May.
What?
It actually got into it with them being like too,
why are you chairing the skis?
Showed up in the fucking third quarter.
But you know,
he probably had been like,
oh that's because I spent the first two quarters in the press box.
Okay,
my last name is Trojan.
My Dad owns the university,
you know,
just one of these fucking cops,
you know.
But of course,
you know it was with the good looking girlfriend.
She does.
She's at that age.
I know what I mean.
She's going to hit your wagon to that.
She sees what the fuck?
An absolute sweetheart.
God,
that's got to suck,
man.
If you have a daughter,
right?
She marries a Douche,
you know the two,
first of all,
you don't want to,
you don't want it to be hanging around some fucking pussy.
How it either cause you're like,
all right,
this guy's going to cheat on her,
break a fucking heart,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Give her a fucking STD.
And then you've got the other thing,
if you just marries a dose,
you know you got that weird,
the feeling where like,
okay,
at least she'll be taken care of.
Cause you know he has money cause he's a Dosha and doesn't care about things and
would portion the water supply if had got them another scarf in life.
All right,
so you want them to come home with like a fucking,
he wanted her to come home with an hour.
They'll fucking uh,
I dunno with like a nice guy,
but then you meet him,
he's a nice guy and then somewhere you're going to resent that kind of really
like this guys to fucking nice
to really go out and make it,
you know,
you just going to accept things,
and
make Pumpkin bread and
I'm a fucking idiot.
All right,
let me just,
let me just plow ahead here.
Let's get to the questions.
Oh,
by the,
I saw a movie on the plane ride out here,
a movie that I wanted to see.
Uh,
there was a movie
called dope that came out I think last year.
It's fucking brilliant.
Such a great movie and the performances in it and the way it's written,
the whole thing,
wire to wire was just done
so perfectly and it's one of the best movies I saw.
I was riding now with my buddy,
we were on the same flight and um,
we got another passenger to switch so we would fucking hanging in drinking on
the way out to go to this fucking game.
We just had the best fucking time.
And uh,
I started watching that movie and within like five minutes,
a million fucking give them the elbow go,
dude,
you got to put this fucking movie on.
And um,
just the whole way that they executed the thing was phenomenal.
Um,
so definitely check it out.
You like,
what's it about?
It's about,
uh,
a kid who lives in the inner city and he's not in a gang and he sucks.
It's sports and he's a fucking nerd.
He's a total fucking Geek.
It's the kind of basically black kid that they net really never put in movies.
You know what I mean?
Cause it's like the other two are exciting or living exciting lives.
Like when you're in a gang,
there's life and death shit going on.
And then we,
you know,
if you're fucking playing in sports,
you know what I mean?
That's like a,
you know,
three,
two,
one,
you're going to have that whole movie thing going and sad to say.
Those are the two fucking kinds of like,
yeah,
black guys that they put on TV,
the gags on cops so that on TV,
crushing your team's hopes and dreams.
That's it.
They never show the fucking nerds that are down there that enjoyed books and
want to go to college and want to get the fuck out of there.
So not only that,
is it an original thing like,
oh,
this part of the city and they're going to do this.
This feels new.
It's actually socially a great thing to show there.
I'm off my fucking tree stump.
It's a fucking great movie.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
to the cubbies of down to,
Oh,
Toronto is down to low.
Um,
does this weird thing that,
you know,
if the cubs are in the world series,
um,
I'm going to be in Chicago at that time doing three nights,
three nights of shows.
And my agent was already worried going through that city is going to fucking
shut down.
So there's a possibility we'd have to move the,
the,
the shows later,
you know,
who knows what the deal is going to be.
We have to accommodate the people in Chicago.
So I'm like,
I don't give a fuck,
move it,
move it later.
I don't give a shit,
I'll scalp a ticket and go to the when he goes,
all right,
done deal.
So I actually really liked the match this year because,
uh,
one of the guys I work with on f is for family sweetheart of a guy's a big mets
fan.
He's a fucking die hard mets fan.
And when it looked like the mets were shitting the bed,
he had this happy go lucky attitude about it going like,
you know,
cause he actually got me into it like back in August.
I go to the mets win last night and he just laughed.
He goes,
no,
we lost again.
I go,
I'm sorry guys.
Yeah,
we're going to blow it.
We're going to blow it.
I go,
you're still going to watch.
So it goes,
Yep,
you got to watch every game.
So just seeing a true fan like that,
I kind of got me on the fucking bandwagon.
Um,
but I also love the cubs too.
I actually,
for some reason it makes no sense as a boss of fan.
I kind of really liked the mets too,
but I also,
you know,
the cubs,
he got to root for the cubs being a red sox fan.
Solidarity.
They go through a curse.
I want to see them win.
Right.
Get that monkey off the back.
As much as I can't stand people who wave hankies during fucking games,
I give you a pass if you're a Steelers fan,
cause they came up with it,
the terrible towel,
you know,
for the love of God,
can you be a fucking sports fan and puts your hanky down,
standing up,
waving that thing to people behind.
You can't see.
It's the playoffs.
Playoffs.
People want to see it.
Um,
all right,
let's read some fucking questions here for the week.
Uh,
yeah.
The plants come around.
All the dishes come out with the fucking noise makers in the hankies and the
signs get out of the fucking way.
There's a reason why there's stadium seating is so the person behind you can
see,
he starts standing up flailing you fucking arms around trying to get on TV.
The rally monkey.
All right.
Halloween movies.
Um,
hey there,
Billy on elm street.
Um,
I would've gone with nightmare on elm street.
Uh,
are you into horror movies?
I've heard every podcast and I'm not sure you've ever talked about it.
Uh,
what movies scared you as a kid?
there was a movie where this fucking maniac,
this chick was skating I bought,
I've talked to about this for,
she was figure skating and then all of a sudden this fucking hockey playing
Jason,
they just show him skating slow motion with this big muppet shoes.
All right.
That was the funny thing.
They couldn't give him like,
I don't think they gave him real skates because it would seemed to fucking
normal.
He still had on his Frankenstein shoes with blades underneath.
It starts fucking skating,
look like them up.
It's on ice.
But then you see as an Elica sickle starts skating towards his fucking lady and
he pulls out the fucking does sickles and she's got this stupid chick figure
skates right,
where you can only do that fucking scissor run.
You know what I mean?
He can't do the fucking hockey thing.
It's so fucking hilarious to me that they gave chicks there.
You know,
you'd figured that fact that,
especially back in the day,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
We're so many sexual assaults were like,
well what were you aware and you are asking for?
And you'd figured that they'd give the women the better skates.
So then the fucking rape has guys would,
you know,
would have to do that fucking figure skating scissor thing to try to catch him
as a fucking would fly up the ice and they'd get away.
You know,
it's a travesty.
That one scared me on the first night,
uh,
Friday the 13th Friday the 13th part one and two was scary.
And then once it went into three d kind of went off the rails.
Um,
dark knight of the scarecrow.
Okay.
Scared the fuck out of me.
Old School once.
Um,
okay.
There was an old sesame street one that scared me when they were trying to teach
you about
okay.
The number one or being alone or something.
They don't show it anymore cause it scared the fuck out of me.
And years later I talked to my younger brother about it and said it scared the
fuck out of him too.
So I imagine somebody wrote to the show saying those freaking kids out,
he starts to song and he's on the piano and he's singing and it was like three
of them up.
It's there and by the end of it he was all by himself and he was running around
going,
hey,
where'd everybody go?
And he couldn't figure out how to get out.
It you just fucking scared as shit.
I Dunno what the fuck it was.
The age I was at,
it was dead whole thought of being alone and not near your parents.
I was just old enough to understand that I didn't know what the fuck I was
doing.
I couldn't drive a car and that,
uh,
okay.
I'd never see anybody that I knew anymore and what the fee was like.
One of the most terrifying things.
All right,
so I went to sesame street there.
Um,
anyways,
he said,
what movie schedule is adult,
anything you can tolerate as an adult.
My personal favorite was the almonds.
What was the one where the guy fell under the ice and they were digging at the
Isis?
He fucking went by.
That one scared me to the Blair witch scared the shit out of me.
I saw that by myself,
the midnight showing I totally buy him when I go to crew.
Scary movies.
The ring scared the fuck out of me.
I found the American one more scarier than the,
the,
the Japanese one.
Um,
some of that shit over there.
The,
the audition.
Do you ever see that one old boy?
Just see that one.
Bobby Lee told me to go see those two.
Bobby Lee knows all about those fucking things and yes it is because he's Asian.
And he is a movie star and you combine the two of those and he's going to give
you some great fucking movies.
Um,
yeah.
I,
I'm one of those guys that I buy into it.
I hate people that go to scary movies and be like,
hey movie dude.
He scare me.
I was laughed into the whole thing.
You know,
like all of a sudden now they're like a war hero.
It's like,
yeah,
you're right.
A movie the whole time you've got a fucking movie.
We just started looking around at the movie theater.
Yeah.
You're not going to be scared,
but if you actually buy in,
which is what you supposed to do.
Yeah.
You're fucking actually have a good time.
You can't.
All right.
Um,
ex girlfriend hinting at possible.
Oh Gee.
MMM.
Ex-Girlfriend handing it possible reunion.
Hey Bill,
love your podcast.
Even though I'm a lady and thank you.
I have no women fans.
Oh,
I assume this was a guy.
Look at me being all heterosexual here.
I'll just get right into it and say,
I've been having some lady problems.
My ex girlfriend.
Do you know how bad I want to have a beer with you and talk to a fucking woman
about women problems?
Just to hear that fucking perspective.
Okay.
You know,
with your fucking insight,
being a woman,
you know what,
what are your moves?
How do you fucking walk through that mine field?
She goes,
my ex girlfriend,
whom I loved for a long time.
And you use the word whom I never know how to use that correctly.
If anybody can send me something,
I've read it on,
you know,
I know how to use your and your and to,
and to t double.
Oh,
I know how to use those.
Right?
But uh,
uh,
who and whom?
I've always stomach my ex girlfriend whom I'm just assuming you're using it
correctly.
I've loved for a long time keep saying she misses me and hinting at us getting
back together.
Even though we've been broken up for like five years.
It's one of those relationships that never seems to die.
Not in the sense that we keep breaking up and getting back together.
We've never done that,
but that we can't just be like normal friends.
There's,
there's always some underlying romantic feelings in our interactions.
Yeah.
It sounds like you guys had that sex vibe,
you know what I mean?
And then you're both relationship people and next thing you know you're hanging
out,
you have a great sex and then the next thing you know you're in a relationship.
Okay.
And then you really realize like,
you know,
we just sort of fucked each other's brains out.
But other than that,
there was nothing else there.
But then when every time you run into each other,
there's still that a,
we could,
uh,
go fuck each other's brains are that you could fuse for the spark of love,
sort of guessing so far anyways,
in case you're not familiar with it.
This is typical lesbian drama.
Okay.
I didn't realize that,
but it makes sense.
She got the same hardware.
You know how the engine runs.
Like she would probably,
I would think that you guys were all fucking crushing it out there.
Right.
Anyways,
it's widely believed that we just can't let go.
She had a girlfriend up until a few days ago,
but kept flirting with me even when they broke up.
Well,
she's a piece of shit that you can't get with her.
He can't,
he's just fucking around with this up broad right now.
She keeps saying stuff like,
what do you think it's going to be like when we're old and married?
Oh God,
yeah.
And then she goes,
oh,
I forgot you don't.
Oh,
she goes,
oh,
and I forgot.
You don't want to get married.
I'm okay with us just living together.
I don't know if she's kidding or what.
So I just tried to dodge it by saying stuff like,
I dunno,
maybe I'll be dead by.
Yeah,
exactly.
She's getting in your fucking head.
I need to confirm.
No,
reject the idea of us getting back together.
I just let her run with it.
I'm not even sure why she's doing this.
Um,
she wants to talk to me all the time now and I'm thinking maybe she's needy and
has been and has been for some time since the relationship wasn't going that
well.
That's what I would guess.
And I'm just a safe target for her to throw her emotions out and get something
back.
There you go.
I agree with all of that.
But then she talked about how she will never love anyone as much as she loved
me.
And when I asked her if she still loves me,
she said yes.
Uh,
you know what?
Can I ask you a question?
Do you love her?
We think of,
were you even thinking about this broad until she got back into your fucking
life?
She's going to fucking turn you all around,
Huh?
God,
let me read the rest of this,
but I don't know what kind of love and what she wants with me.
If she's serious or just having fun.
I'm not going to say I've never thought about it,
but I'm not sure if I'd ever go back to that relationship.
We broke up for a reason and even though there's still something there,
it seems like a huge step backward in a way.
Well,
there's your answer.
What the hell does she want bill?
She wants you to fucking clamp.
She wants to nuzzle up next year and have somebody watch a movie with and fucked
around with again so she can fucking drive you nuts.
And he got to go through the emotional drama again and why now?
You're already answered the question cause she's recently single and she's
lonely.
Thanks for your time.
When you freak podcast a lesbophobic grandmother.
Oh that's the next question I thought I'd tell you.
You signed it.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
Your grandmother and your afraid of lesbians,
you are a lesbian.
What are the odds that was going to be the next one?
Sorry about that.
Um,
I would say a yeah,
I would not get back involved with her.
Fuck that.
You still young.
Go get yourself some hot piece.
That fucking is into you so it can be exciting and new.
Come aboard.
Were two lesbians.
Let's hang out
and we're our shack.
It's two gether please.
Um,
yeah,
that's what I would do.
I would move on.
Oh,
what she wants to now because she's recently single fuck that.
She's using you all right.
You better than that.
You're better than that.
Fuck that.
And don't give in to the fact,
you know,
just the way this whole thing is written.
I feel like you're alone,
you're a better person and that you actually have more genuine feelings.
You know what I mean?
Which means you're going to be more vulnerable and easier prey.
And I think she's coming in,
you know,
she's basically the lesbian version of the dude that sat behind me during the
USC game.
The douche is Douche.
She's like the lesbians content,
you know?
Does that make any sense?
It probably doesn't,
but I'm looking out for year.
I would say do not get back together with them.
All right.
Especially over the holidays.
You know that Wednesday before Thanksgiving when you just want to go out and go
to that place,
you know basically the lesbian chairs,
sometimes you are to go right where everybody knows your name and she's going to
be sitting in there drinking some sort of pumpkin beer.
You know it comes walking up to you wearing or Dickie ca.
You don't need that shit.
Fuck that.
Go talk to that.
Younger hottie in the sun,
dress to yourself.
Treat yourself this holiday season.
Get yourself a younger hardy in a sundress.
All right.
Lesbophobic grandmother a dear Billy Ball buster.
Before I get to what I want to talk about,
I just want to say that I'm a big dude and user ever inspired me to lose weight.
Goodman's since April 3rd,
I've been working out almost everyday and have lost 35 pounds.
So thank you for that bill.
You're a legend dude.
You're a legend.
That's fucking tremendous switch.
You got to do,
go to the gym every day.
My big thing is,
I'm on the road for two weeks here,
so you know,
um,
I've actually stayed on my gym schedule.
I went to the gym the first day,
second day was my day off,
and now the next three days in a row,
I do three on one day off.
So,
uh,
I'm doing my podcast and we're driving down to Cincinnati.
Just want to get to Cincinnati.
Um,
you know,
it's not a long drive,
so I'm going to,
I'm going to do the old treadmill.
Hopefully they'll have a pull up bar or something there.
Um,
so I can do my pull ups and that type of Shit.
cause I have a bet with Paul Versey that when I'm 70,
I'll be able to do 10 of those fucking things.
I was actually thinking the other day,
if I can pat myself on the back as I was on my peg board in my garage,
which I have the long skinny one that actually hung sideways.
So I just go along the thing sideways because you know,
you need like fucking,
you need like a fucking,
you know,
10,
10 foot ceiling,
probably 11 with the size of my head to go up a peg board and have the head room
to get up to the top.
And I didn't want to hang it lower and start,
you know,
with my fucking basically on my knees for,
for whatever reason,
I didn't want to do that.
Um,
and I was going across the peg board and I was actually thinking at some point
going through it,
I'm 47 years old going across the peg board at some point.
I got to be impressed.
That's pretty impressive.
Um,
and after Bert Kreischer gave me that,
that men's health thing do Cretia grip strength that really helped me on the
fucking pegboard.
Um,
and also my technique I held,
you know,
when you hold it,
you got to have your,
your basic,
your forums almost touching your bicep and you've got to have it and then the
rest of your arms basically right on your side.
He got to get in close.
Um,
so you got more leverage.
I was almost,
I had my arm too far away from my chest and I couldn't do it.
Um,
so anyways,
he goes a few years back.
My parents got divorced after 17 years of a bad marriage.
We'll put the final nail in the was my mother's secret relationship with another
lady who is now her girlfriend who I'll call Kate for the sake of this email.
Kate with a k not with a c,
like all Bruce there.
She has since moved in with us,
which sounds weird,
but my brother,
sister and I all have a great relationship with Kate.
Um,
also I wasn't,
it wasn't just something my,
Oh my God.
Can you imagine that poor bastard?
What a mind fuck that is,
dude.
If you're in a relationship,
okay.
And it ends and it turns out the other person's gay.
I mean,
you have to be sitting there going,
this person never loved me.
Yeah.
I just wasted my fucking life.
And then on top of that,
your family bonds with the new fucking lover.
That's just a double mind fuck.
Like,
is there any sympathy from me?
What the fuck I'm going through?
I legitimately love this fucking woman.
Wow.
Anyway,
she's since moved in with us,
which sounds weird.
My brother's a citizen.
I have a great relationship with Kay.
Well,
that's,
I mean,
yeah,
that's good.
That's actually progressive also.
It wasn't just something my mom,
uh,
also,
it wasn't just something my mom just drove into.
In spite of my dad.
My mom and Kate really do love each other and they have three strong years
together.
To back that up,
dude,
you got any sympathy for your dad?
Uh,
here's the problem.
My grandmother has grown farther and farther apart from your mother ever since
she turned the lesbian turn lesbian.
They'll do.
She always,
she was always there.
Uh,
she pretty much hates cake too,
by the way.
You can't turn gay.
You're gay.
You know what I mean?
You just,
you,
she fucking gay.
It's like,
did you turn heterosexual?
Was it a decision you made?
You know,
it's like four or five fucking years of age.
The first time.
That's the first time I remember.
Okay.
I always tell this fucking story.
Whenever somebody says turned gay,
it's like you are what you,
I remember I was laying on the floor.
They're this giant rug.
When I was in kindergarten and this girl asked to get up and go to the bathroom,
she could go to the bathroom and I was laying there playing with some fucking
toy,
you know,
holding it up like a little kid does.
And she,
she walked by me,
she walked by close enough that I could see up her skirt to see her five year
old side,
which sounds weird,
but I was five,
so I was crushing it.
Right.
And when I saw it,
you know,
I felt like this fucking jolt in my heart.
And I remember I sat up and I just turned around and stared at her and she
walked out like,
what the fuck was that?
You know,
this wasn't a decision made.
So I imagine if you were gay,
right,
am I really going to talk about five year old balls?
I can't do that.
Um,
yeah,
it's basically the same thing.
But to say that you turn gay would mean that you also turn heterosexual,
which means at some point you were sitting there and you know,
metaphorically or hypothetically,
whatever the proper word is,
there was a deck and a pussy on the table and you will go and eeny meeny miny
let's see,
what are we going to choose here?
Let's weigh the options.
You didn't,
you would just straight.
All right.
Anyways,
so she pretty much hates Kate and she believes she has perverted my mom.
Uh,
she won't even so much as come over for a meal and I can barely mentioned Kate
around her mind.
You by grandmother lives only nine houses down from us.
Here's my question,
is there any way to make my grandmother more accepting of my mother,
my mother and Kate.
Her option hasn't budged in three years and I'd love for her to at least be
cordial.
You're infinite and hilarious.
Wisdom will be greatly appreciated.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Um,
no,
I'm sorry.
I usually offer a ray of light.
There isn't,
there isn't.
This is going to be one of these deathbed thinks that she's going to have to
fucking through there just there isn't a,
when somebody feels that way,
feels that strongly.
Um,
all I can say is just keep inviting her to stuff.
Maybe eventually she'll come around.
I was surprised that in all of this she didn't have any,
nothing about your dad and the shit that he had to go through them.
It's fucking unbelievable.
You know,
they actually did an article about that,
you know,
when,
when Bruce became Kate,
you know,
and they will go,
oh my God,
isn't this amazing?
This is fucking,
you know,
and then fourth line gets the 4th of July because everybody was so afraid to be
on the wrong side of that issue.
Then all of a sudden,
you know,
they'd lose their advertising and then they couldn't make their mortgages.
That's what most of that reaction was about,
I felt was about,
you know,
cover your ass.
Let's get out in front of this story and show how much we,
uh,
you know,
we are accepting of this or like pieces of shit.
Espn,
let's ignore a woman dying of cancer who splits still playing basketball and
let's make fucking Kate the sportsman of the year so that we get the exclusive
interview with her fucking pieces of shit.
Um,
anyways,
the fuck am I going with this slight,
they actually did this article and informed article on it that wasn't homophobic
but actually talked about the people that were married and the depression and
devastation that they go through.
Cause they,
you know,
they lose that person.
You know what I mean?
Like Bruce Jenner has got,
and if you loved Bruce,
do you want to fucking relationship,
you know,
with them.
Mike,
his wife was,
I mean,
all of a sudden,
poof,
just fucking Dessy bad.
If you go to a fucking do,
it's almost like they died.
So,
I mean,
there is a crazy thing there.
Or if he ever relationship where all of a sudden there's nothing more
definitive.
I think that if you,
your partner never fucking loved you the way you love them.
If not only do you go through a divorce that they then you find out that the
whole time that they were gay.
So it's just like,
I would be going like,
oh my God.
So as I like grossing you out,
every time we had sex,
I would be fucking devastated.
So I was a little surprised he got nothing in there about your dad.
I mean,
he must be like,
ah,
fucker.
He,
he cause he crushing it.
Maybe he's got some fucking young chick on the side.
I have no idea.
But I'm getting away from the,
uh,
the thing here.
Um,
I would say no,
there's,
there's no way when somebody is that walled off and you know,
okay,
on one level you just gotta be accepting of your grandmother that like,
she grew up in a different time in her child brain was filled up with this shit.
And you know,
it's,
it's fucking atrophy in there.
There's nothing you can do about it.
But yeah.
Okay.
I Dunno,
just keep coming over the,
I,
you know what I would do,
I would openly joking.
I would openly joke about it in front of her to loosen her up.
You know,
that's what I would do.
I just remembered when we remember that guy,
that old guy that lived beneath me last time when I had the apartment way back
in the day and you still always yell at my wife through the floors and he was a
fucking asshole.
We just started being overly nice to them.
My wife started whistling and Adam,
Mikey was a good looking guy and we fucking basically wore the guy down and at
some point,
you know,
before the dementia set in and he totally went fucking crazy.
You,
I was standing on the fucking porch,
but just a tee shirt on.
That was a hell of a site.
I would just openly joke about it.
Um,
I would just be like,
uh,
I would start calling her Kate that you hate.
That's what I would do.
Hey my mom and Kate that you,
hey,
that's going down to the store.
Hey,
you know Katie that you,
Haiti.
Yeah,
they're going,
they're going to go to the movies still probably holding the hands right now.
Grandma,
they're holding a heads grandma.
Like I would just do that.
Okay.
I'd be like,
come on grandma.
There was never one,
you know?
Okay.
You never had one half a second gay moment,
you know,
it was just one girl.
I don't know what she did.
You just admiring her beauty and yet,
I don't know,
maybe just wanted to kiss her on her shoulder and just try to grow surround,
which is really,
I've just,
I would,
I would break a balls about it
every time I saw him.
I would do that in the beginning and then I would talk to her about whatever I
want to talk about.
That's what I would do and see if he could,
and then I would tell Kate that that's what I'm doing.
And then when Kate there,
I'd be like,
grandma,
there's Kate.
Thank you.
Hey.
Oh,
Haiti Katie's.
There she is.
Look at her,
you know,
as much as you hate her,
you got to admit this is a hell of a meatloaf sandwich.
Granted,
you're not.
You don't want to know where this fit those fingers where when you were,
she was making it.
Don't,
don't take it that far.
I'm sorry.
Had to get out of it with a joke.
Um,
all right.
Yeah.
Girlfriend.
Uh,
fuck the yoga instructor.
Hey,
old Billy bald tits.
How the fuck are you a,
I'm writing you because I need some advice.
I just recently found out my girlfriend of two years is done.
Okay.
Some fucked up shit.
Up until now.
I thought she was marriage material.
She's not like the Kardashian wannabes up today.
She and I have so much in common and we always laugh and I love hanging out with
their no red lights.
Hey,
even no red flags.
You mean I've been triggered until now.
Uh,
she doesn't drink like crazy.
She doesn't take off her heels and walk home or he's not a quitter.
Overall,
she's awesome.
But recently I found out from a mutual friend that before she met me,
she had a secret affair with her yoga instructor.
And that's not even the fucked up part.
The Yoga instructor is also her best friend's Dad.
What?
Okay are best friend's dad and she never told her best friend.
Oh my God.
So that Yoga instructor fucked his daughter's best friend though dad is such
yoga instructor behavior.
Okay Dude,
I'm telling you right now and another fucking life I would have been a yoga
instructor to those guys.
Fucking crush it.
Like nobody,
dude,
hot chicks,
they all fucking do yoga,
right?
Cause they want to stay in shape,
but they don't want to get all fucking bulked up.
They want to keep that senior we tight muscle,
right?
They want to be all tone but still look good in a fucking dress,
So he keeps like the Pied Piper.
They just come to you and you get them all stretched out before you fuck them.
And then you can have your whole new agey,
blah blah blah.
Dude,
I'll tell you right now,
take a yoga fucking class one time in your life.
And you know who the yoga instructor wants to bag.
It's the one they always go over and they adjust them and they put their hands
on them,
you know?
You know what I mean?
They get the f the,
the woman gets to feel their fucking touched and they're all fucking open
because they're fucking in this headspace.
Like the whole for the fucking vibe is,
it's,
it's a layup.
You know,
it's funny,
I just take this fucking yoga class and this guy was like crushing it.
And for some reason I was always doing the positions correctly.
He never had to adjust me,
but the fucking chick next to me who was already totally stretched could put a
foot up her own goddamn clamp for some reason.
He always had to fucking adjust her.
Their Spaghetti straps.
Uh,
fucking hilarious.
Ah,
you got to love a piece of shit.
Yoga instructor.
I fucking,
oh,
there's such dirt bags and the whole time that talking about all this new agey
stuff,
you know,
just be man,
he can't fight it.
You know,
just fucking give into my Dick.
Um,
anyways,
he said they fucked for a few months before she met me and came clean to telling
me,
uh,
that it was true,
but she regrets it.
What the fuck do I do?
I'm Young,
I'm only 22,
but I feel like I have really found some someone in her,
but I feel like I can't trust someone who would be that deceitful.
Should I move on or assume something like this won't happen in the future.
Thanks a million and as always go fuck yourself.
Well,
those are two really great questions.
MMM.
You know,
in defense of her,
she's really young and I'm assuming that fucking guys,
at least in his forties and what he did was barely legal.
You know,
dude,
that guy fucking spit 20 years a game at her door in a yoga class.
I mean,
it's a fucking layup.
MMM.
But also
she did fuck a guy.
She did fuck her friend's Dad.
So,
yeah,
if she's the way that you say what she's this really wholesome,
innocent type person,
those people are also,
you know,
the kinds of people that ended up in the trunk of serial killers,
cars.
I hate to say it because they are so fucking innocent and that type of shit.
So you know,
this guy's basically Jason,
except instead of an axes use in his dick.
I mean that's just fuck.
That's fucking,
oh my God,
I can't imagine doing that.
I can't fucking up.
Can you imagine
right after you bust a nut in your,
you're thinking clearly again,
what the fuck you just did.
And you know,
women are so fucking emotional,
right?
Jesus Christ like,
and they just have to talk.
You'd never rob a bank with a woman.
I mean,
you caught before it's even started and then you do something like that.
And then I'm like,
God,
I feel so bad.
I said about Gal.
And she goes down and as a couple of fucking lady drinks and the whole fucking
town knows,
oh my God.
Then your daughter hates going to hate you for life.
You're marriage is fucking over.
I'm like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Okay.
Jeez,
that guy,
my gig minds are stuck.
His Dick in a beehive
son of a bitch got away with it because he's a fucking yoga instructor man.
Um,
okay.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I would just really come clean to her and I would just sit down and say,
listen.
MMM,
just tell her all these great things that you feel about her.
But the,
the fact that she did it did that
you just need to talk about it more.
Like just ask a walkup were way to it.
Like why do you think you did that?
Just don't accuser don't be like,
don't be having an accusatory tone.
Don't be judging her even though you are.
Um,
I think the jury's still out on that because she's so fucking young and that
piece of shit is so fucking old.
Um,
he really took advantage of her.
I don't give,
I know it's fucking legal,
but to me in my head like,
yeah,
you're a fucking pervert if you do something like that.
Yeah.
I'm judging the guy.
I mean,
she loves was 21,
22 when he did it.
But that,
that that's not fucking right.
Yeah,
that's,
that's not fucking right.
You know,
um,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah.
I've seen pornos with a more wholesome storyline than that,
you know?
Uh,
no.
I would just ask her about it and just to,
why you,
why you do that?
What did you do that,
why,
why do you think that you did it?
I would help her get through it in a therapy way and just by her answers,
if,
uh,
you know,
if that's like what she's into,
then I would have some concerns that she would act out again.
Um,
I dunno,
I,
but I,
but if you love her,
you really got to sit down in a non judge judgment away.
And by the way,
dude,
you telling me you haven't stuck your Dick in someplace that would give her a
little bit,
some fucking red flags.
You never did anything filthy,
you know?
Okay.
I mean,
I'm assuming you did.
Why don't you be fair and kind of,
it's this weird thing where like,
you should be before you marry somebody,
you,
you have to,
you got to judge them.
You don't just walk into it blindly.
You're agreeing to spend your life with somebody.
You got to judge them harshly.
But,
um,
she already feels bad about it.
You know,
you don't want to hurt her,
but I,
there's,
there's a way more of like a therapy kind of way.
He could just ask them like,
why?
Why do you think that you did that?
And if she goes,
well,
why are you still asking me about it?
Which she might,
she might get defensive.
I would just say
I,
I don't know because I,
it's,
it concerns me.
That's a bad answer.
What do you mean it concerns?
You don't owe chases do.
This would be like dismantling a bomb.
I just put,
got me inside a hell of a story.
Like how did you keep that a secret?
How did you feel about that?
She probably needed to get it off her fucking chest.
I think the fact that she had to admit it to you,
it shows that she's not a complete sociopath,
you know?
I Dunno.
Okay.
Let me know how that one goes.
I gave you the best advice I could.
All right.
Bye curious girlfriend Jesus.
This is like the red shoe diaries is fucking weaker.
Um,
hey,
bill.
Recently I found out that my girlfriend who I've been uh,
with for a year now has been searching on the Internet for naked girls in porn
with hot girls is I was on her phone in front of her not snooping.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure you weren't snooping.
This was of course news to me and I confronted her about it,
which ended up in her being embarrassed and upset.
She promised me that she's never been interested in girls in that way.
However,
she told me that she does find girls attractive.
Dude,
what is the fucking problem?
I love this girl and she makes me very happy this word me because even though I
am confident young and good looking male and made me feel insecure about myself
and feel that I'm not enough for her,
well that's very honest.
Um,
love the podcast,
especially the vice [inaudible] videos as I usually agree with your outlook on
different situations.
So just wanting to see what you thought about my situation.
Should I be concerned or should I just forget about and continue to be happy
with that?
Thanks to go fuck yourself.
Whether there's a number of ways that you can go with this.
You can either break up with her and then you're not with her.
You can,
uh,
drive her to indulge in this tree,
attraction and then get yourself a threesome amount of it.
But you probably gonna fuck up the relationship because it never fucking works.
Once you have that open fucking thing,
and then we have rules shy,
I have to be there and then eventually you won't be there and then it'll be
fucking weird.
And there'll be three people in the room when you have the breakup talk.
Um,
I dunno,
dude,
I'm,
I'm really big on not like judging people.
Like,
you know,
when it comes to that type of stuff,
like the sex stuff and the shit that they're fucking into because I still think
we're just scratching the surface of 'em
of all the shit.
Like I don't even think we even understand it at this point.
So I think it's perfectly okay if she's into that type of thing.
I actually think it's kind of cool and,
um,
no,
I wouldn't,
there's no reason to feeling insecure.
You know what I mean?
Think about the porn that you've watched this debt.
You definitely got something in your sexual fucking closet that she doesn't
fucking know about.
You know what I mean?
Something that you're,
until you're,
until like older chick.
So who the fuck knows what right.
The fuck knows.
I,
I think,
I think like
to really have a great relationship,
you kind of,
you just got to accept the,
there's that fine line where you have to know what you're willing to accept and
what you're not willing to accept.
You got to know where that line is.
And when you're young,
I think you're still learning that.
So that's why you're writing me.
Just figuring out where that line is and if the person's on this side of that
line,
then you just have to be totally accepting of them.
MMM.
They,
once they know that they can relax and you have a great fucking relationship,
you know?
Um,
not to toot my own horn,
but I have a great relationship with my wife and,
uh,
in part of it is because we do that with each other.
Like she,
you know,
she accepts me for the fucking lunatic that I am,
and I am a fucking lunatic.
MMM.
Like,
I don't,
it's the weird thing of me getting with her is I realized how fucking nuts I am.
And I don't mean like,
Hey,
I'm a crazy guy.
I like to drink beer and smoke cigars.
I mean,
like,
there's something fucking a little off about me.
And,
uh,
she accepts it.
She had to give a fuck.
You know,
on the surface.
I'm a great guy.
I'm sitting there making pumpkin bread,
you know,
working my ass off,
bringing home money.
But,
uh,
the other underneath there,
like I'm a fucking,
I'm an,
I'm a lunatic and a,
I'm such a psycho that I'm only just now realizing it and I can't even,
I can't even like verbalize what it is about me that makes me a fucking,
uh,
I dunno.
Like I am unbelievably,
I'm an antisocial son of a bitch.
I will tell you that right now.
Do you know I'm sitting in a hotel room right now with a TV that does not get
proper reception on a football Sunday.
Yesterday I could not get proper reception for the games and rather,
and I just shut the TV off because I'd rather miss the fucking football games
then to call down to the front desk and have to socially deal with somebody
coming in here and fixing the TV.
I just don't want them in here.
And while he was fixing the TV,
I would be sitting there.
I talked about this last night thinking like,
what if I just took my laptop and just smashed him over the fucking head
repeatedly right now,
you know,
I just think shit like that.
I wouldn't do it,
but that's what I would be thinking.
Okay.
And the whole time he's helping me,
every time he would talk,
I would just be in a hostile way thinking,
shut your fucking mouth.
And that's just one of those ticks that I have it,
she accepts me.
Um,
oh,
I didn't read the last bit of the advertising here.
Oh,
by the way,
thanks to everybody that came out.
MMM.
To the show last night in Fort Wayne,
Indiana.
I'm looking forward to Cincinnati.
You going to try to get some fucking ribs when I'm down there?
That's what they're known for.
Um,
all right.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
You shouldn't have to choose a random lawyer who charges expensive hourly rates
when you need legal help.
But the legal system is so complicated.
What are the choice do you have when you need help with your business and want
to protect your family?
Well,
start with legal zoom.
They make it easy for more than a decade.
They provided a way for regular people like you and me.
You know,
we're not good at math,
right?
We don't have a trust fund.
We're just regular folk walking down the street,
eating a corn dog to confidently navigate the legal system.
Legal Zooms,
not a firm.
That's how they provide such great value.
They don't rely on charging you by the hour,
man.
Instead,
you'll get transparent pricing and customer view so you know exactly what you're
getting upfront.
If you need help with the incorporation,
LSCs trademarks,
last wills,
living trusts,
and more legal zoom is the smart choice.
They've got the right people on hand to answer your questions and if you need
legal advice,
their network of independent attorneys can provide the straight forward guidance
you need.
And most states,
uh,
don't let legal hurdles become an excuse.
Go to legalzoom.com today to start building your own future.
The right way to save even more.
Enter burr in the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com Promo Code Burr.
And lastly,
but not leastly,
stamps.com everyone mailing and shipping are routine part of your,
of running your business important.
Keeps your operation important.
What keeps your operation going?
Is that a fucking sentence?
But if you're making constant trips to the post office,
that's a routine you need to change.
There's a much more convenient way and that stamps.com stamps SOBCon brings all
the surfaces of the post office right to your desk.
Buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer.
Print postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of male than just handled to your mail lady,
our mailman a you'll never waste valuable time going to the post office against.
He can focus on what really matters growing your business.
Uh,
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters,
right?
Anytime I'm pouring myself out.
I'll do that in Madison Square Garden.
I've got a poster for that one.
I'll be sending it out and if I can figure out how to use this scale and all
that shit soaking you right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last name,
birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes postage and a digital scale.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type of burpee.
You are our,
that stamps.com enter burr.
Um,
Alrighty.
That's the podcast for this week and uh,
to how good do the fucking Canadians look?
They're looking to go six and all those fucking red,
white and blue cunts.
And San Jose actually has the nerve to be an undefeated.
Can you believe that?
They're going to do it to the fans again.
They're going to get them all excited just to shit the bed again in the
playoffs.
Who knows?
Who knows what will happen.
All I know is the Bruins got another game coming up.
Uh,
I think tomorrow I'm going to try to watch it when I'm on the bus.
As always.
Thank you to everybody who's,
uh,
been listening to the podcast.
Everybody who came out last night,
I'm selling the last of my DVDs on the road here.
They're all autographed and when they're gone,
they're gone.
Just like Cadbury eggs.
Um,
and that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll just check it on ya on Thursday.
All right.
Have a lovely couple of days.